hello everyone I hope we're all having a
great Saturday and as it is Saturday I
know you're all busy with your hobbies
and activities so I thought I'd surprise
you with a wonderful chess puzzle now
the first time I saw this puzzle was
probably some 10 years ago but I also
saw it a couple of days ago again I saw
it and avocadoes Facebook page and
probably a lot of you don't know who
David lada is but a lot of you have seen
his work
so I thought I'd take this opportunity
to introduce the guy to you in his early
days he was an active chess player later
he became a chess journalist his work
has been published in most of the
world's renowned chess magazines and
today he is known as a renowned chess
photographer very often you will see a
photo on the cover of a chess magazine
that was taken by him so do check out
his work I will put a couple of links in
the description below following leading
to his social media and his website and
if you really enjoy his work you can
even acquire this book he just made it's
called the thinker's this is the book
and it features a hundred and
ninety-three high-quality photos of
chess players all around the world it's
a great book to have for when your
family comes over for when your friends
come over even if your girlfriend comes
over you can just show her let's say I'm
just gonna grab one here you can show
her a nice photo of a silly bunch up
here here you can see it and this is a
this is a full-color photo but there are
also some black-and-white photos there
are even photos spreading over two pages
so it's quite a lovely item to have and
I mean it's a lovely item to have if you
enjoy chess but even if you don't enjoy
chess not if you don't enjoy chess but
if you have a family member or some
friends that don't really follow chess
it's a great way to introduce them to
chess that these are actual people who
are playing chess and I don't know
probably someone who doesn't follow
chest they just think those are some
no-name people sitting across the board
and making moves and that's really
boring but this way every photo has been
taken like in the exact moment that was
right and then you can really see how
how how wonderful the chess world really
is so that's what I wanted to tell you
and the reason why I'm kind of promoting
this is because he also promotes chess
he also promotes just on a global scale
he promotes chess on a daily basis and
well it seemed reasonable since this
channel I run here it's basically a
channel to promote chess so it seems
seems reasonable to promote someone else
else who also promotes chess and another
reason is I use a lot of his photos for
my thumbnails so if you don't follow the
photography you've seen his work on my
thumbnails when you click on my videos
so that's that's the thing I wanted to
say hope I introduced him to you and I
do hope you check out his work the links
are in the description below so let's
check out this puzzle what's what's this
all about this is a puzzle composed by
Gannicus Padian he's an international
master from Armenia and he got his
national master master title in 1936 in
1950 he got his international master
title and this is a puzzle he composed
in 1935 so he composed it even before
becoming a national master and not only
was he a composer
today he is considered to be one of the
greatest composers of chess and game
studies but in his younger days he was a
very active chess player he won the
Armenia Chess Championship ten times
twice he tied for first place would
feature over a world champion Tim Burton
which Petrosyan so a great chess
composer and and an excellent player
obviously so this is the puzzle I wanted
to show you and don't don't just watch
the solution I will give you a hint it's
white to win and white has to checkmate
black in seven moves so white the mate
in seven and don't just I mean posit of
course try to solve it it's not it's not
an easy puzzle it will take you even if
you're a great
players will take you probably some 10
minutes so don't don't feel forced to
solve it immediately you can even just
pause it and leave it somewhere in the
browser or make a print screen and maybe
try and solve it when you have time
because you'll really enjoy you know
you'll really feel good about yourself
if you solve it so I will give you some
time to pause the video now and like I
said don't just watch the solution try
to solve it so for those of you who were
able to solve it congratulations it's
it's probably one of my top five puzzles
I've seen in my life and so it's just
amazing so let's let's see the solution
first move for white is definitely
ignite the e8 and 98 is with the idea of
Knight to g7 check followed by Bishop to
a5 or Bishop to a5 followed by Knight to
g7 check depending on what black plays
not not the not the most precise way
would be knife to f5 play Knight to f5
and then like immediately escapes with
King to g4 and now he has an escape
route so Knight the e8 is the first move
and now black has a couple of options
here you can of course catch on capture
on f4 you can capture on h4 you can
capture on f4 let's say with the rook
you can push f5 you can push g4 so a lot
of options here so let's explore some of
them if you capture for example G
captures on f4 now you get Knight to g7
check King goes to g6 and now comes a
Bishop to a5 and this is checkmate so
this is not the solution we're looking
for for those of you who are new to
chess or maybe new to solving chess
puzzles when I say it's checkmate in 7
moves that means it's checkmate in 7
moves if black plays the most correct
moves so if black defends properly so
after this night to e8 move obviously
capturing an f4 doesn't work capturing
an h4 doesn't work just as well even if
you capture with the rook it's the same
idea
97 check King goes to g6 and now comes
h5 check
rook captures on h5 now Bishop to f5
check rook captures and now g4 if you
found this solution this is a this is
also acceptable but this is a checkmate
in six moves it's not in seven because
black didn't play the most precise moves
so after this night we a move we have
another move let's write g4 f g4 is
played doesn't really matter again 97
check King g6 and Bishop to a5 checkmate
there is a little difference if black
tries to move f5 now we have to capture
with the bishop on f5 first because if
you go Knight to g7 check first then
King can escape through g4 so first you
have to capture it Bishop captures now
you play G captures on h4 and now comes
Knight to g7 and this is checkmate so
none of these moves are are very good
for black after nice to e8 the solution
you have to find is king to g6 this is
blacks
strongest defense and this is where the
fun starts here you have to play h5 t h5
comes with a very very subtle idea
one way to blunder this position would
be to push f5 because after f5 and rook
captures on f5 now you can't really push
h5 because king can capture on h5 and
after Bishop captures now yes you are
threatening Knight to g7 checkmate but
black and pull g4 and he makes an escape
route for himself on g5 so after this
King to g6 move the correct a move order
is actually h5 check forcing the rook to
capture if you capture by the king if
King characters then simply again Knight
to g7 check King has to go to g6 as
bishop is covering the g4 square and
again Bishop to a5 check so the King
can't capture the pawn rook has to
capture it rook captures and now comes
f5 and now the rook is forced to capture
as the bishop is guarding f5 rook
captures and again a beautiful move if
you really solve this then I'm sure you
felt extremely good when you found this
move pawn to g4
and what's the idea of pawn to g4 well
black can't move any of his pawns and he
can't move the King so only thing he can
do is move this rook or this rook
problem is if we move this rook for
example rook to h1 then comes Bishop
captures on f5 and this is checkmate so
your only other option is to move this
rook so let's say rook to rook to e5 and
now comes again a beautiful move Bishop
to a5 check and this comes with the idea
that you again want to force the rook to
capture on f5 and now the King again
doesn't really have anywhere to go and
now comes the most beautiful move of the
puzzle Knight to g7 and this is this is
amazing as you can see the pawn on g4 is
attacking both rooks here and the knight
and g7 is also attacking both rooks but
more importantly the knight is also
guarding DF v square and the d h5 square
so here it doesn't really matter what
black does if black moves this rook then
pawn captures rook on f5 will be
checkmate if black moves the f5 rook den
pawn captures on h5 will be checkmate as
like I said the knight covers the f5
square and the h5 square so let's say R
up to h1 simply Khan captures on f5 this
is checkmate let's see the other rook
moves rook F 1 then pawn captures on h5
and this is again
checkmate so there were a lot of
variations here and you really I'm sure
it took you some time to figure out all
of this out but let's see it one more
time from the beginning so checkmate in
7 for white it's a forced variation with
if black defends properly Knight to e8
now King has to go to g6 we said this is
the best defense now first h5 check rook
captures if game captures then it's made
into now comes f5 the rook is forced to
capture rook captures and now comes g4
we already said that if the age group
moves pawn captures Bishop captures an
f5 is checkmate
so the other rook has to move and now
again comes Bishop to a5 check forcing
the roof to capture rook captures and
now Knight to g7 and this is one
is one beautiful structure this is I
mean this Armenian guy Gannicus partying
is was really something rope to h1 and
pawn characters on f5
this is checkmate and this is the
solution to the puzzle once again I
truly congratulate everyone who managed
to solve this puzzle as it's definitely
not easy and you know it's it is a
forced variation but definitely not an
easy one like extremely extremely tough
puzzle so yeah that's it I do hope you
enjoyed it as it's Saturday I haven't
posted a puzzle in quite a while Sora so
I thought I'd surprise you I would like
to thank Antonio Morocco couch look
Vikas Bradley Campbell ignacio's
Fernandez and Jorge fart for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - all my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon with another great classic